how can we quickly find the average of
the numbers you're seeing on the screen
let's see
let's take four random numbers two three
four and seven the average is the sum of
the numbers divided by the total number
of numbers the sum of these four is 16
and here there are four numbers so 16
divided by 4 gives us 4. now look at
these six numbers if you try to find the
sum of these numbers then it will take
us a lot of time so what's the solution
for this
if you observe closely you'll see that
all the numbers differ from each other
by three
this plus three gives us 108 this plus
three gives us 111 and so on
there is an easy method to solve this
for evenly spaced numbers the average is
the first term plus the last term
divided by two here the first term is
105 and the last term is 120 by solving
this we get the answer as 112.5
we saw how easily we got the answer
remember first term plus the last term
the whole divided by
using the same concept can you tell us
the answer to this in the comment
section for more such interesting math
concepts do subscribe to our youtube
channel